la nouvelle a eu l'effet d'une bombe ce
mercredi la direction de renault a
annoncé la suppression de 7500 postes
d'ici à 2016 sans licenciement ni
fermeture d'usiné les salariés semblent
découragés et écuries je pense que psa a
commencé hier à et ils occupent leur
usine à aulnay bon ben je pense que ça
c'est une toute façon c'est une réplique
à faire on va pas je comprends le bien
les collègues on va pas continuer à
monter des voitures si on sait que et
bien la fin du mois ou dans trois mois
c'est fini quoi ça sert à quoi il ya
donc une forme de dégoût des coeurs
membres parce que bon ils ont vraiment
le sentiment qu'on tape toujours sur les
mêmes et puis la deuxième chose dans
quelque chose qui s'était déjà amorcée
avec l' affaire de faux espionnage c'est
la perte de confiance totale dans la
direction un document interne révélé par
le parisien ce jeudi tablerait en
réalité sur 8260 départ
cela concernerait 4100 départs naturels
dont 2150 via les retraites et 1950
personnes qui devrait quitter
l'entreprise au titre de la ld m c'est à
dire pour cause de licenciement
démission ou mobilité en 2012 les ventes
de la marque au losange ont diminué de
plus de 21%
selon les syndicats ils étaient près de
300 à s'être rassemblés ce jeudi matin
au sein du technocentre de guyancourt
les mouvements de grève devrait être
organisé dans quelques jours la
prochaine réunion de concertation est
prévue le mardi 22 janvier